c'est pas la question essentielle la
question essentielle je ne pensais pas
monsieur vincent ledoux merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé madame la ministre
le gouvernement auquel vous appartenez
malheureusement en train de réaliser
cette triste prophétie de mauriac
c'est merveilleux la vieillesse dommage
que c'est fini si mal savez vous que les
ehpad de notre vieux pays connaisse
d'immenses difficultés
je suis pour ma part admiratif de leurs
personnels qui accueille prennent soin
accompagne nos aînés malgré des
conditions de travail toujours plus
difficile mais surtout un manque
pathétique de moyens ainsi à tourcoing
la résidence des flandres a augmenté sa
capacité d'hébergement de 30% sans que
les ressources de fonctionnement soit au
rendez vous malgré les incessantes
relance de l'adjointe au maire auprès du
directeur de la rs il leur manque
toujours à ce jour quatre cent mille
euros
comment voulez-vous d'ériger des
établissements avec une telle absence de
visibilité et dans un contexte
d'alourdissement de la dépendance comme
à bousbecquois roncq et tourcoing n'est
que l'arbre qui cache la forêt d'une
misère sidérante dont je peux témoigner
sur l'ensemble de ma circonscription
le pire c'est que je connais déjà votre
réponse les éléments de langage d'un
gouvernement qui préfère dénoncer avec
une absence totale de partialité le
programme à venir de la droite plutôt
que de faire son autocritique
avec bernard gérard nous écoutons les
infirmières les médecins les aides
soignantes qui nous parle du désastre
bilan des 35 heures à l'hôpital
il veut mieux que quiconque en parler
alors madame la ministre
au lieu de vous ériger en chevalier
blanc de la fonction publique
hospitalière alors que vous l'avez
conduit dans une terrible situation
qu'allez vous faire pour répondre aux
attentes extrêmement importante de ces
personnels soignants qui assure pourtant
la continuité du service public louis
barthou disait la vieillesse peut
devenir une parure sans être une
abdication n'abdiquaient pas madame la
ministre mais par eno ehpad des moyens
nécessaires
je vous en remercie merci la parole est
à madame la ministre de la santé et de
la protection sociale merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député le doubs je vais
répondre précisément sur la situation de
votre ehpad
mais je veux dire que lorsque j'apporte
mon soutien à toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien dans les
établissements pour personnes âgées
dépendantes le fait et en conscience et
en apportant le soutien nécessaire et
les moyens de leur action je sais qu'ils
elles travaillent souvent dans des
situations difficiles mais je veux vous
dire monsieur le député que ça n'est pas
en leur préparant un temps de travail de
39 heures payées 37 comme le fait votre
candidat que vous allez améliorer la
situation du travail dans les ehpad ni
dans aucune administration de santé ni
dans un aucun os aucun hôpital de france
alors vous évoquer la situation de la
résidence des flandres qui est un ehpad
géré par le centre communal d'action
sociale de la ville de tourcoing et vous
exprimer vous le vous relayer des
inquiétudes au moment où la convention
qui unit le département le ccas et l'
agence régionale de santé convention qui
fixe les moyens pour l'établissement
doit être actualisée et vous dites que
des réponses ne sont pas apportées la
première réponse qui vous a été apportée
monsieur le député ce sont des moyens
financiers puisque l' agence régionale
de santé s'est mobilisée depuis le mois
de septembre dernier et à attribuer des
crédits supplémentaires à cet ehpad dont
je vous annonce et j'imagine que vous
saluer l'action du gouvernement dont je
vous annonce qu'ils seront pérennisés en
2017 ce qui va permettre de porter les
crédits qui relève de l' agence
régionale de santé à un million trois
cent mille euros
mais vous savez fort bien que les
crédits d'un ehpad ça n'est pas
simplement l'état c'est aussi le
département et je suis obligé de
constater que votre département a baissé
ses engagements auprès des ehpad et il
lui appartient donc de s'engager et de
s'impliquer
ou la résidence des flandres comme le
fait le gouvernement merci madame la
séance des questions au gouvernement et
terminer la séance est suspendue